protesters outside australia's
parliament
demanding action on violence against
women
in recent weeks allegations of rape have
rocked australian politics
prompting a growing number of people to
speak about sexual assault
and harassment i don't want to grow up
in a world where women aren't listened
to
and i think that we should make a change
it was sparked by shocking allegations
that former political staffer brittany
higgins was raped
by a colleague in the defence minister's
office
we are here because it's unfathomable
but we are still having to fight
the same stale titan fight
australia's top law officer attorney
general christian porter is also accused
of an historic rape
dating back three decades which he
categorically denies
police have closed the case but the
government is facing growing calls
for an independent inquiry we just
don't think that it's appropriate that a
man who holds the highest law
office in the country can have an
untested
and also apparently unread rape
allegations sitting out there it makes
women feel very unsafe
and unsupported allegations of misogyny
and sexism in australia's parliament are
nothing new
the nation's first female prime minister
julia gillard called it out in 2012.
but stories of a toxic culture continue
it's still very much a blokes
world here a man's world and even if you
work in the building
as a woman you know very clearly
that you're not in charge the government
says violence against
women is a priority and has set up an
investigation into workplace culture
but many don't believe that goes far
enough
this isn't just about women in politics
many others here have their own story
about being harassed or sexually
assaulted
they're calling for systemic change from
the top down to make sure women
are treated equally some are calling
this latest movement
australia's second metoo wave stories
all too familiar right across the globe
nicola gage al jazeera canberra